millennial Milenio means a generation
that actually puts a focus on not just
profits but purpose a group of people
who are focused on having an impact
doing good maybe doing it in some
unconventional ways but it's about
making sure that that's your North Star
versus doing what's called unquote
conventional or expected from previous
generations my name is Ryan Williams I
am 29 years old and I am the CEO and
co-founder of cadre what cadre does is
pretty transformational we are building
the world's first digital stocks market
for alternative assets we're focusing on
commercial real estate but ultimately we
want to transform any industry that's
been opaque illiquid and inaccessible to
most members of our global economy
the best part about being an
entrepreneur is bringing together a
group of people and aligning them on a
common vision I look at my role as an
entrepreneur and a CEO as effectively
the captain of our team and first and
foremost I need to make sure I get the
right players on the field second I need
to make sure that the right players are
positioned for success they're in the
right roles that's really really
challenging and it plays into sort of
what the worst part about being an
entrepreneur is when you're disappointed
or letdown in some ways by decisions
that aren't necessarily aligned with
what you think the team's collective
goal vision or purpose should be but I
take a lot of pride in helping people
will be the best versions of themselves
I take a lot of pride and getting
constructive criticism feedback and
guidance I think as long as everyone
knows we're working towards the same
goal you know you can work through any
of those challenges or adversity